for the cults that it's just you know
there's a chance that this was just a
perfect storm
of good circumstances for them if it
works if it works but again my point i
think they've done enough homework to
convince themselves they could be wrong
but they've convinced themselves that
it's going to work
and i i don't blame them for doing that
and i don't blame them for thinking that
it could work i think what frank wreck
did last year with philip rivers is a
good example of what can happen when
it's right especially when frank wright
knows the player already and he because
he had phillip rivers uh there in san
diego with the chargers and so if you
have that relationship that's previously
established we have seen already what
frank wright can do with a quarterback
and so if that's what they're thinking
they can do with carson wentz
more power to him because look philip
rivers did not have a good year in 2019
with the chargers and i was covering the
raiders at the time so i saw him twice
that year and it just looked terrible
when he was trying to throw the football
i remember that thursday night game that
they played in oakland it was just it
looked so ugly when he was just trying
to throw the ball i thought he would
flame out and really have a bad year
with indianapolis and then he didn't so
you know who knows i could be wrong
again on carson wentz and how this could
work out i think that carson wentz has a
good chance of being a viable starting
quarterback
and i think that because of all the
talent that they've got in indianapolis
and the coaching that they have there he
can definitely be a viable starter but
does that mean i think he's going to get
to an elite level where that he's going
to be able to push the colts past these
teams in the afc that ostensibly are
better than the colts right now i'm
talking about the browns the ravens the
titans in their own division right the
chiefs of course the bills at the top
there i don't know if carson wins can do
that for indianapolis
i was with yon rivers too he had those
seven interceptions in back-to-back
prime time games and when the colts gave
him 25 million the same amount the
saints gave drew brees the same amount
the buccaneers gave tom brady i thought
that that philip rivers was in i should
be wearing a ski mask when i signed this
contract territory i couldn't believe
they did it but they got to the playoffs
with him and they gave the bills
everything they could handle so maybe
maybe they know how to draw the best out
of someone
who is embattled to say the least so
where do you think
let's say
let's say carson wentz
on a pass fail scale passes let's say
he's good enough what does that mean for
the colts as it relates to potential
success in 2021
well if he passes i think it just means
that he's either playing 70 of the snaps
and they go to the playoffs or he plays
75 percent of the snaps because that
would mean that the draft pick becomes
of
the one as opposed to the two so that to
me is the pass fail scale i guess so if
he fails that means that that that
second round pick stays a second round
pick and i i don't know i think that the
colts can probably be a seven win team
to as much as a 12 win team depending on
where carson wentz is and that just is
the fluctuation of how bad he was you
know last year in 2020 to how good i
think he can be which is probably like
the 2019 level i just like i said i
don't see him getting back to that mvp
level if he's at an mvp level then the
colts i think are automatically in that
upper echelon of the afc teams with the
bills and with the chiefs i just don't
know that he's going to be able to get
there but like i said if he passes that
means that he's playing a bunch of snaps
and he starts the whole season and that
that that second round pick becomes a
first round pick
miles i can't tell you how refreshing it
is to have someone who uses the term
upper echelon correctly on the first try
i have been working for the past few
years with someone who
insisted that it was upper echelons
he'll be back on monday and i'm talking
about chris
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports